it's really good to see you ron
you've aged horribly you
son of a [ __ ] oh my god
what is your problem nothing's changed
has it
he set the bed on fire excuse me i did
okay is that what you wanted
we're fine we're fine please take it
easy
when you meddle in someone's personal
life it's just so
rewarding
oh yes baby got it
[Laughter]
grace where are you you're making a huge
mistake
are you karen yes honey well
peter paul and mary you are fabulous
well thank you who are you
i'm jack jack oh
will's jack well hello honey we've
talked on the phone a million times i
can't believe we've never met
look at you you little hottie stand up
no come on
look at you you are a rocket ship oh get
out of here are you
a strange person this is
what is this p.s
loving the boobs
perky with all kinds of attitude
store-bought
right ah god i had no idea you would be
so
kidding with a whip come on let's touch
stomachs
oh my lord you are a complete freak
ron and i are going to get a cup of
coffee and talk things out
it's time for tammy and me to bury the
hatchet once and for all
everything will be fine
[Music]
it's been like this for hours
hey swanson snap out of it
leslie congratulate us
ron's got one just like it on his penis
oh yeah
what the hell happened to you
well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's been kind of a crazy night come
back come on
hello
[Music]
i don't want my scrubs
hi my name is karen walker
oh my god that voice is ridiculous
oh hospitals are fun
she's here who's here my ex-wife tammy
too
i can smell the sulfur coming off her
cloven hooves good nose ron tammy
swanson is here she'll be my next
witness
tammy too is your killer witness please
you're gonna have to do better
actually she is a terrifying sociopath
who could say or do anything
a pretty good killer witness miss
swanson
do you as you claimed have evidence
linking
leslie knope and ben wyatt to law
breaking absolutely
i have several photographs that will
definitively prove yeah remind you that
you are under oath and if you lie i will
fire you and have you prosecuted nothing
they will definitively prove nothing
well you cut me off i don't have any
evidence oh
chris it's so silly okay bye guys leslie
have fun with this trial yay
i'm going to the barney still with
rosario this weekend why don't you just
come along
well i'll need a little money from the
atm
denied denied approved
this could end up being the best night
in ron swanson's life
i am so so happy for him hello you
gorgeous craftsman
wow look at this room so much wood
ready to be worked
me hey alert alert alert alert
she's here isn't she oh hey ron
what a coincidence gosh i never dreamed
you'd be here
tammy this is diane diane this
is a piece of human garbage named tammy
who is also my ex-wife
trisex wife we were married twice and
divorced twice
everything is done they're totally done
what's going on what's happening what's
with the tv
oh i'm watching what i would call
the feel-good movie of my life
[Laughter]
did you rent pretty woman again
come on give it up honey the only thing
you two have in common is horse teeth
and bad taste in men
[Laughter]
you're a filthy little piggy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
karen something you want to tell me
what's going on honey what's happening
why aren't you licking that floor
oh all right it is me but it's not what
you think really
cause i think it's you and a maid's
uniform
whipping some old guy in a onesie am i
wrong
come on it's just a little fetish film
oh my god how did this thing get into
circulation
oh my god this is the end of me
i don't think i can go on karen what are
you
doing karen don't be ridiculous there we
go nice and cold
[Applause]
oh boy just one question is dirty little
pig boy the other white meat
come on spill it well i was just out of
college i was broke it's the oldest
story in the world
boy meets girl boy wants girl to do
dominatrix film
girl says naked boy says yeah girl says
forget it boy says okay
then just wear this rubber dress and
beat the old guy with a scrub brush girl
says how hard
i've given this a lot of thought we
should break up
what's the matter little boy did the bad
people get to you
they just made me realize how unhealthy
this is literally
all the steak and whiskey i have to wear
a diaper that's cause you're my little
baby
we drilled you on this jam baby talk
what do you do
i'm not a baby i'm a big boy yeah okay
well that wasn't terrible don't listen
to leslie she's trying to manipulate you
all she cares about is herself and i can
prove it
how's this leslie you leave us alone and
we
swing the vote to you help you get your
park
no nice try stay strong jeremy
it's over tammy tell you what it's been
long enough
what do you say we consummate our
relationship
tonight huh let's
do it and the last
card is played what are you doing shh
this is a library you see what's
happening here ron i need that crotch
blinder
no you don't just end it
look at my boobs no look downstairs no
there's a prize inside for you
it's over tammy what the hell with you
woman
goodbye how dare you are you
kidding me you'll be back they all come
back
well done jeremy turns out the crotch
blinder was inside you all along
stan get off of me
[Applause]
where am i
you